I got an A which is my best friend's
initial and my initial and I got the
Venus which I'm on it together long but
they're beautiful thank you very much
Ariana Grande shows off her new ink as
brother Frankie weighs in on her new
rumoured relationship with Mac Miller
we're loving your sister and her new
boyfriend they seemed really happy to
get it does he get the brotherly seal of
approval one Ariana's happy I am happy
so you'll you'll I'm sure you'll get a
chance to speak to Ariana later because
she's performing tonight but yeah
whenever whatever makes her happy makes
me happy that's official they were in a
tattoo parlor that seems pretty did they
get matching tattoos I I don't I what I
literally have been locked away in the
Big Brother house you're giving me more
information that you can know yet
well Ariana stayed mum on her new beau
she gushed over her new music video for
side to side with Nicki Minaj a new
music video is premiering tonight at
midnight what can we look forward to
being with it Oh too busy asking me
annoying things we don't do that hey to
Entertainment Tonight no I'm very
excited about it some hearing on the
guest website I'm really excited about
it it's my favorite one so far